the world is coming to an end people but
fear not CNN is going to walk us through
it that's right some video leaked I
guess this week showing what CNN has
planned for when the world comes to an
end but before we get to the video let's
look at a statement from CNN's Ted
Turner barring satellite problems we
won't be signing off until the world
ends will be on and we will cover the
end of the world live and that will be
our last event we'll play the national
anthem only one time on the first of
June the day CNN launched and when the
end of the world comes we'll play nearer
my God to thee before we sign off okay
so that's what he said originally when
they came up with this idea that the
world was going to end and that they'd
have to do a little quick programming so
now let's watch the video
[Applause]
[Applause]
I know if the world was anything that's
how I would want to spend my last
minutes watching that um look at you
know media outlets they have to prepare
for [ __ ] right there are obituaries for
everybody over 50 that they have stock
stuff ready to go every now and again
you see them get leaked online it'll be
like not to be published and they
accidentally reveal that someone's died
and they haven't all that so I guess
this is just them doing their due
diligence no I used to work for a news
company and we did have obituaries
things that we would use in case of
there was a natural disaster but you
know then that would lead into a live
reporter doing something that is more
timely it was funny cuz I saw it said
HFR which is like news feed for hold for
release yes end of the world
hey enemies wait what do we want maybe
an updated film file of better quality
yeah I like to say the world is ending I
mean let's do it in high-def right like
have they updated that is the question
Jeff Zucker took over CNN did he say
guys you know let's update the end of
the world do a hip hop burn right
something you know it's the late 90s and
then it's like oh here we go
Katy Perry's thinking nearer my God to
thee like what that's what we have now
that's what we've hired how we should do
it every every few years we need to
update definitely not be like for its in
a four by three the original video yeah
and like how about that ambient noise by
the way we have a noise canceling audio
programs now where we can get rid of
that low Rumble in the but remind you of
something that would air maybe like in a
disaster movie yes he's not a flickering
TV yes the embers of society burn out it
definitely looks like the beginning of a
commercial on the first day of MTV
before like Sammy Hagar yeah yeah stiffs
yeah but uh there was another thing I
thought about this but I forgotten it
well that's alright um what are you
gonna do when the world ends like the
idea that anyone would be sitting there
you know the world and so let's look the
world's ending so I assume this means
aliens are attacking or global warming
but if it's global warming that's gonna
happen slowly so this strikes me more as
like we know what comets coming you got
five minutes left
you're not going to be watching TV
wouldn't you what would you do
at the end you got five minutes left
what are you doing saying if it's
zombies
I have sword training I'm gonna go out
there and I'm gonna live you'd be the
Michonne of our network maybe yeah you
would be I believe that she definitely
be the Michonne you would be the trying
to be the first you did the little girl
who's like going like this in the first
scene you know like I would be that I
was gonna pay first I was gonna peg you
as the scientist with the mullet I don't
know why yeah right yeah I know we're
back um what would I do what would you
do you got five minutes left meteors
coming the aliens of the zombies I don't
know take vampires
Thanks something ridiculous jerk-off
that's yeah I'm probably just make make
you know I want to have a little bit of
pleasure the last few minutes I would I
like about this video though is it's
like there's so much pressure not to
play it before the actual end of the
world that I doubt they'll ever get a
chance to play well that's the beauty
like all hell's breaking loose and like
what are you gonna send some PA or some
intern don't forget to press the button
on the like that's who I am
I'm gonna suck ground and do that right
I'm is it Wolf Blitzer Wolf Blitzer is
gonna press the bike Blitzer you know I
Blitzer I'm carrying him up to the
camera and then I'm slowly crawling
toward the tape ah get it in there get
it in there to get make sure it plays
before the world ends so dramatic yes